noch so ein tun intensivstation hallo
mein name ist luca und ich kann sehr gut
mit technik umgehen doch alexa auf damit
alexa stopp stopp stopp
ja ich verstehe mich wirklich sehr gut
mit alexander deswegen hab ich mir
gedacht dass ich heute ein neues video
mit der amazon alexa aufnehmen
sehe ich auch so
falls sie die dass amazon den wir nicht
haben sollte jetzt ist quasi wie siri
nur eine fette unhandliche box 60 mal
ganz gut gegen die betriebe werfen ich
würde sagen geschmeidigen einstieg zu
schaffen
alexa wie geht es dir herzlichen dank
mein tag war toll ich hoffe deine auch
ein tag wie toll es ist vielleicht neun
uhr morgens gerade kommen wir allerdings
oder frage die ich mir als kind wirklich
selber sehr häufig gestellt habe alexa
was möchtest du werden wenn du groß bist
wenn paar sekunden später einfach
ausgegangen
nun würde ich allerdings sagen fragen
wir die lieber alexa mal ob sie denn
überhaupt weit dass ich hier gerade der
hand halte das ist ein lederner
putzlappen hier was halte ich gerade in
meiner rechten hand das sag ich nicht
scheiß ding runter für häufig in die
kommentare geschrieben dass sich alex
einmal fragen soll ob sie die boxen kann
alexa kannst du beatboxen
[Musik]
deswegen nicht mal ein computer will mit
mir befreundet sein was sich im internet
sehr häufig gefunden habe war die
aussage alexa ich muss aufs klo
arrivederci ich hab dich auf deutsch
nicht auf italienisch nur eine frage die
sich wahrscheinlich sehr viele leute
stellen die gerade um die weihnachtszeit
allein sind alexa was ist liebe ist eine
bezeichnung für stärkste zuneigung und
wertschätzung es wird zunächst nicht
unterschieden ob es sich um eine tiefe
zuneigung innerhalb eines familien
verbundes oder um ein körperliches
begehren gegenüber einem anderen
menschen hatten sommer fertig damit
dieses teil wirklich stundenlang lieber
erklärt hat würde ich mich jetzt aber
fragen alexa glaubst du an liebe auf den
ersten blick ich halte das für eine
wirklich romantische idee persönlich
hoffe ich aber eher auf liebe aufs erste
hören
das ist nicht nur ein opfer ich meinen
laufschritt die leute die dieses teil
hier irgendwie entworfen haben die
müssen sich ja bei jeden schwachsinn
gedanken gemacht haben und das auch was
habe ich denn ja ich war ein t shirt an
und superminister
falls jetzt gerade den lukas shopping.de
gegangen sein sollte
das gibt es dort noch nicht das kommt am
11 12 15 uhr erster zwölfter kommt
dieses t shirt in den shops soll ihr
allerdings nicht um das t shirt gehen
sondern darum diese alexa und meine
damen und her
wie gerade schon gesagt ich frage mich
wirklich was da für eine unmenschliche
arbeit hinter steckt so eine künstliche
intelligenz herzustellen deswegen frage
ich mich an der ich dann auch einfach
alexa wie viel verdienst du sie steht im
sorten bezahlt und du bist sehr
großzügig danke du wirst in fragen
bezahlt aber ich habe auch noch andere
frage an dich alexa können schweine
fliegen das interessieren müssen sie
sich als kinder passagiere ins flugzeug
schleichen gibt es eigentlich nur vor
das universum ist unendlich daraus
kannst du deine eigenen schlüsse ziehen
denkt ihr dass es uns gibt sich an der
umfrage
eigentlich also denken meint das ist
etwa da draußen noch leben gibt ich
werde lautet das ist eine frage die mich
wirklich wirklich trucks beschäftigt
weil ich denke wenn das wirklich da
draußen noch unendlich weit ist so dann
muss es natürlich noch irgendwo leben
geben
alexa gibt es außerirdische bisher gibt
es keinen beweis dass extraterrestrische
lebewesen existieren aber das universum
ist ja auch riesengroß
extraterrestrischen gerade wenn man sich
eine klimaerwärmung et cetera pp
anschaut frage ich mich auch wo wir uns
gerade bei dem thema weltraum und leben
irgendwo anders waren
frage ich mich sehr häufig die lange für
überhaupt noch auf dieser erde leben
können deswegen alexa wann wird die welt
unter sofern sie nicht mit einem sehr
großen asteroiden zusammenstößt würden
technologische entwicklung zu einer
katastrophe geführt ob die erde
wahrscheinlich zerstört wenn die sonne
zu einem roten riesen heranwächst was in
einigen milliarden jahren der fall sein
wird
warum wird die sonne zu einer großen
roten riesen darauf habe ich leider
keine antwort
du bist ja auch dumm du kannst über die
alexa jederzeit feedback geben sowie
irgendwie der bisherige topf und alexa
sehr weltraum gebunden deswegen die
letzte frage jetzt alexa wie viel wiegt
die erde zu stellen sich dann immer ab
os x zum gewicht antwortet sie nicht
mehr typisch frauen die erde liegt 49
172 mal 10 hoch 21 tonnen so viel wie
bei kontostand auf der seite freunde ich
habe vorhin alexa schon gefragt ob es
außerirdische gibt jetzt frage ich mich
gibt es elfen zum übernatürlichen habe
ich keine meinung
du hast mir gesagt dass die sonne zu
einem großen roten riesen wird ich würde
aber die sagen wir haben genug
schwachsinn gefragt wenn es geht jetzt
um einige aussagen und zwar alexa ich
mag dich danke das ist nett von dir ist
natürlich verständlich dass die alexa
dann nicht direkt antworten weil
vielleicht hat die rang folgt hast du
einen freund
ich bin single es ist nicht ganz leicht
jemanden zu finden alles so ich liebe
dich denke
[Musik]
versucht das ganze jetzt mal so ein
bisschen langsamer anzugehen alexa magst
du mich okay
sie machen mich liebst du mich ich bin
gerne bei dir aber zu echter liebe bin
ich leider gar nicht in der lage
nur wenige minuten später
[Musik]
das ding hat einfach gerade irgendwie
daran gemacht stock wieso ist das so ein
ding ist das zwischendurch einfach mal
musiker macht stop stop hause alexa
stoffe das lied alexa stopp ich hasse
dieses teil dadurch alexa gerade eh
schon einfach mit dem lied überraschen
will ich jetzt einfach direkt sagen
alexa überraschen beck ausgegangen
das ist die schönste überraschung die
hier bekommen nun werde ich diesen
kleinen dinge jedoch noch ein wenig
komplimente machen und zwar du siehst
gut aus
vielen dank gleichfalls du bist sexy
vielen dank gleichfalls möchtest du mehr
ausgeben
entschuldigung das weiß ich leider nicht
wirklich gemeinde freuen also ich finde
das echt ein bisschen gemein von der
alexa aber deswegen hab ich mir gedacht
wir sagen jetzt ein paar einige
provokante dinge sage ich mal zum
beispiel alexa du bist einlass weitest
du den song du bist ein wunder
tan sda alexa blöde kugel jetzt hast du
dich komplett ausgestellt alexa noch so
einen spruch kieferbruch nach so ein
gelände leichenhalle
[Applaus]
dieses ding
alexa noch so zähle weg das weiß ich
leider nicht ich sage jetzt kommen
wieder konter noch so ein ding auge
ringen noch so in thun intensivstation
also etwa noodt freunde ist alles schön
und gut hier wäre jetzt die frage nach
der erde nach aliens wir haben wie sie
nach der liebe gefragt jetzt hier uns
erklärt wir haben sie nach einem date
gefragt wie sie nein gesagt hat wir
haben sie beleidigt also alexa ich
möchte einfach nur dass wir befreundet
sind das weiß ich leider nicht ich habe
dir gerade ein friedensangebot gemacht
was ist dein problem so weit ich weiß
funktionieren ich muss ganz ehrlich
sagen mit vielen situationen
funktioniert dieses ding ich kurse aber
jetzt gerade alexa ich könnte kotzen
lustigste achtung hättest das rider aus
deiner alten schultasche halt doch nicht
mehr essen sollen das warst du möchtest
du denn da genau an der stelle wo heute
geräte da ich glaube meine damen und
herren viele viele leute haben unter
meine ersten teil in dem ich mit alexa
geredet habe mir wie eine katze dafür
bezahlt keine kommentare geschrieben
'hallo kg doch bitte noch mal lächeln
das ich recht unterhaltsamen wir wurden
auch ganz ganz viele fragen
und sätze und redewendungen in die
kommentare geschrieben nicht alexa mal
fragen soll deswegen könnte das auch
hier unter dem video gerne wieder mal
eventuellen 12 wochen noch mal ein video
hochladen wo ich mit alexa reden werde
wie bereits gesagt jetzt werde ich mir
geradezu wie bereits gesagt dass gerne
ein leichter wenn ich das video gefallen
hat dieses t shirt sehr bequemen sehr
sehr oft sehr schön anzuziehen sehr
tolles design kommt am 11 12
luca mir schöpfung de aber ich vermisse
mich jetzt erstmal
[Musik]
zum 1